jack
is
ladies and gentlemen yeah
that's great thanks jack
it's great to
that's nice
it's
it's great to see you uh but you mean
you did a great cameo on monday night on
our show and it was it was fantastic but
i think we're good tonight i think we're
okay we don't really
go in and trust me i am not here in a
professional capacity i'm just enjoying
the show with my fellow native georgians
don't mind me
fine okay all right
okay it's just that it's a little
distracting having you up there
distracting
you
are a silly man
hopefully continue
okay well i was going to say uh one
thing i found out that george is very
famous for and this is oh my lord
you have brought your a game to atlanta
yes
that wasn't even a joke jack
well this audience member gives it three
thumbs up okay that's great
all right
[Applause]
i was trying to say georgia is really
famous
you are famous there's nothing better
than the bag of piping hot georgia
pecans
with treats like this no wonder
agriculture is georgia's number one
industry
hi jack we appreciate the little georgia
fact it's just that what i found if you
want to cry tears of joy just cut into a
vidalia onion the official state
vegetable of georgia
that's great jack it's just that i don't
know but georgia's not just about nuts
and onions oh no
as recently as 2011 georgia led the
united states with nearly 1.3 billion
dollars in wood pulp exports okay yeah
seriously
seriously jack what you need to do i
need to get back to talking about pecans
sure
the georgia pecan is truly the king of
nuts enjoy them roasted candied or in a
pie okay yeah
great hey jack jack you know what other
state exports a lot of pecans texas
[Music]
you sir can go straight to
good night hell
he got nasty real fast